tarantulas getting thrown from a plane
rectal exams marriage some of the
greatest punishments on Impractical
Jokers might not be what you expect
Joe's punishment in the season 3 episode
female has Joe dressing up as a woman to
perform in a fashion show except not
really work it buddy work it buddy
that's it Joe actually has to talk at a
seminar for Tech enthusiasts looking at
new app ideas and the app ideas are
pretty offensive after his immediate
shock Joe is surprisingly comfortable
with his transformation and even more at
home pitching app ideas that he's never
seen before Joe solidifies his
Impractical Joker status here as the one
who can do anything confidently the
punishment lived on is one of the best
and strangest and Joe's later commitment
to equality shows that he gets it and
what better way to stick it to the other
guys
it's rare that a punishment has more
than one loser but the season 5 episode
training day puts Joe Sal and myrrh all
on The Chopping Block Q was previously
embarrassed in front of his former New
York City Fire Department colleagues by
being forced to perform in a musical
about his personal failures in the
episode stage fright keep making farts
on TV after this and another punishment
that ruined his Jeep in carsick Q was
clearly sitting on something big while
biting his time as a result he puts his
friends through a rigorous training
process with the fire academy all three
of them struggle and Joe is forced to
swing an ax through a portrait of his
young daughter
are few and far between the fire academy
outing has been voted among the best of
the best
not only has Sal's haunted corn maze
been listed as one of his best
punishments but it's also one that some
viewers have said they'd have wanted to
tackle themselves the season 3 episode
Field of Screams shows Sal having to
make his way through a corn maze while
holding a guided rope with plenty of
creepy obstacles waiting in line to
scare the life out of him I will not
hesitate to punch him it's one of the
most fun punishments featured on
Impractical Jokers while also setting
Sal up for his later punishment of
moving through a haunted house and
fighting off a horde of sewer zombies
how did he get here by not kissing a
blonde woman on the lips Sal becomes the
instant loser of the devil voices
challenge though its Mur who fails to
get the audience to applaud him while
quitting at the zoo and quit
fantastically Sal eventually loses again
during his presentation about dinosaurs
in dynomite
myrrh takes on a fifth grader in his
season seven punishment during the
episode dropping knowledge of course the
consequences are much more dire for
losing in this version of the famous
game show it's another segment where
first time viewers aren't sure if the
situation is being set up or not though
the camera panning to items being taken
from MERS apartment every time he fails
to answer a question correctly speaks
for itself it's a different kind of
punishment for Mur who's usually
physically humiliated or thrown from
Heights when all that's been done the
only thing left is to insult his
intelligence you're an English major and
Trader Jake is a terrific sport even if
he has no idea what to do with the
shower head betting door handle and
diploma that he wins Mer's journey to
failure was cemented when he took two
thumbs down in the earlier command
challenge Biker Boys when he refused to
make fun of someone's accent
if there's one thing about the
Impractical Jokers it's that their
families are always willing to be
involved in their challenges and
punishments in the season 6 episode The
Walking dread Sal's nieces sacrifice
themselves to a horde of zombies in
order to have Sal save them as his
punishment fans of the show know that
Sal's reputation for being scared of
everything is almost more well known
than he is all he has to do is get a key
the key right there that's hanging right
there
well it looks like you guys are staying
in there Sal's dance with his
apocalyptic Destiny and the sewers is up
there with the show's most memorable
punishments pairing his fear of gross
things with this fear of everything else
it's a finale suited uniquely to sell
Sal's nieces are incredible Sports
especially considering how easily he
crumbles while they seem bored by the
whole situation according to a Reddit q
a with Sal cast members have refused
things in the past but wrestling with a
heap of raw meat in a weird Warehouse is
just on the right side of his boundaries
in one of the most recent punishments on
this list it's safe to say not much has
changed for Sal since his corn maze and
haunted house days in season 10 episode
8 former White House associate director
Cal pen guest stars and takes part in
the final challenge Sal is forced to
tell a stranger that his breath smells
in front of pen multiple times the
situation escalates when the stranger
threatens Sal encouraging him to move
away but Sal is forced to continue Penn
and the Gang delivers something that's
painfully awkward and ultimately the
potentially embarrassed stranger's
imaginary foul breath is redeemed when
Penn tells Sal that it's been his own
breath all along oh my God what's that
I just I have breath
your breath literally smells like with
Joe Gatto having left Impractical Jokers
the move to include a different
celebrity guest star in each episode
seems to be working and this punishment
provides plenty of laughs
former by season 4 of Impractical Jokers
he wasn't a stranger to extreme
punishments The Season's second episode
below the belt sees and giving a
presentation about climate change the
catch is that he has no control over
what the others do to his lower half
while he's behind a table which includes
leg waxing pants wedding and mouse traps
it's so weird fans may remember that
earlier in the episode mer loses both of
the featured challenges sword losers
sees the gang having to do whatever
they're told during a fencing class
while still being able to recruit their
student to sign up for another class
you look like an adult born baby on
guard assets
not all punishments can make you fear
for the life of the participants but
Sal's beastly surprise during the season
7 finale does exactly that though the
episode is technically a one-hour
holiday special it doesn't pull any
punches when Sal is stuck inside a cage
with a bucket of chicken and brown bears
are sent in to keep him company
oh
my god with three challenges determining
the loser across the holiday special it
very well could have been one of the
others in the bear cage since it's not
really something anyone would be
comfortable with Sal's earlier loss in
both the meal or no meal and toy Vey
challenges threw him into the losers
club and a bear cage
season 3 offered plenty of chances for
Sal to scream and get the Fright of his
life one memorable instance happens
during the episode Chunk in the trunk
where his punishment involves getting
into the trunk of a random woman's
rental car fans find out that the
woman's actually in on the plan though
Sal is unaware of this
viewers also enjoyed seeing him being
hit by a loaf of bread on the road to
failure cell got no votes during the
topical storm challenge while presenting
with slides that had little or nothing
to do with the subject Sal also loses
out in stick and spin which has the goal
of getting a specific body part to touch
a stranger's specific body part
when it comes to what fans might
consider the most brutal punishments
anything involving kids is likely to be
high on the list in the season 7 episode
the running of the bullies it's once
again Sal who faces another grueling
punishment tasked with posing as a
lifeguard at a local swimming pool he
has to kick everyone out on the grounds
of bullying with the task unable to end
until the pool is empty though some
viewers found the punishment too painful
to watch others relished Sal's ability
to not just argue with a bunch of kids
but their parents too
10. what makes the punishment even worse
is how well-behaved the kids are
actually being arguably it's all Sal's
fault losing out on both of the episodes
challenges after being unable to get
someone to order an especially weird
lunch in meal or no meal Sao also falls
flat in the team-based command task dust
Buddies
it always comes back to presentations as
challenges and punishments and once in a
while home invasion in the season 2
episode Sweat the Small Things Sal's
punishing presentation is actually a
cover while he delivers a talk that's
designed to be about stress relief the
slides show the other cast members
breaking into his house while Sal was on
vacation abusing everything in sight I
have to move because there's no doubt I
have probably hepatitis A through Z it
got fans thinking about what home
invasion punishments might look like for
the other cast members by season 5 Joe's
home was invaded and completely wrapped
in wrapping paper though Sal lost out
earlier while facing the dartboard of
Destiny when he failed to kiss a guy's
hand it was Joe who became the loser in
an earlier challenge while trying to
teach an art class Joe's habit of being
unfazed by anything would have made this
punishment a lot more boring as he
certainly wouldn't have cared if people
had taken their shoes off like Sal does
from the very first episode onward the
Impractical Jokers Gang has a
long-standing love affair with White
Castle the restaurant is featured again
in the punishment for the season 8
episode fast Feud with Sal having to
work the drive-through orders only it's
not his voice it's coming through the
microphone fortunately for Sal the
punishment had an ending that surprised
everyone
all right Sal it's you some fans have
gone as far as scouting out the White
Castles the team has filmed at with Joe
on hand to help via Twitter Lynbrook and
Massapequa by the way once again Sal is
the only loser in this episode the
opening challenge house sitters requires
the Jokers to try to find someone to
house it for them despite absurd
circumstances and conditions but Sal
becomes the only loser in the follow-up
battle Shadow shoppers
when the Jokers can't get physical they
have to get psychological it's these
unexpected inconveniences that are the
best method to torture Sal during the
season 8 episode well the Joker's
torture Sal without him realizing it by
leaning into everything he's been afraid
of on the show so far the punishment
isn't even something that Dawns on Sal
until after the punishment is over first
he's surprised by the fact that a
punishment is even happening and it
becomes worse when he's told he'll have
to bungee jump then he has to deal with
cats or does he how about a pile of
manure it's not clear that this is all
misdirection until it's all over what's
going with you buddy guys I can't take
it anymore
Q's punishment in the season 5 episode
brother of The Sisterhood sees him
posing as someone who would politely but
firmly disagree as a panelist at a
women's rights event the punishment is
so cringe-worthy that it actually made
its way to a mainstream Reddit Forum
with many Impractical Jokers fans
stepping in to explain that Q had been
set up women love Q he's a Charming guy
he's nice he's brought up right by his
mother yes he's a charm his way out of
this though while it's definitely a
punishment that's considered to be a fan
favorite it almost wasn't a cue that had
to face it Sal lost the first challenge
handing it off by refusing to make a
sarcastic comment about equal pay while
filling out fake questionnaires however
it was Q who was unable to retrieve a
five dollar bill from a stranger during
cash holds unluckily for Q the last
challenge was a double down meaning he
scored two thumbs down instead of the
usual one
the best punishments come as a form of
Revenge and Joe is a fantastic example
of that in the season 7 episode turning
the tables Joe's punishment cease in
finding and breaking eight fake tables
in a real-life restaurant The Challenge
is to figure out which are fake and
which are real by Smashing them this is
happening
oh the punishment was actually Mer's
revenge for an earlier punishment where
he had to take down a female Judo
Olympic medalist during a party he
failed and ended up being thrown in a
pool Joe walks off his definite back
injuries with style in the episode's
impractical Insider feature it's
revealed that the tables Joe broke
through were actually made of foam and
that the people sitting at the
designated decoy tables were in on the
joke everyone else was a real customer
in the season 4 episode elevating the
game its Sal's turned to experience his
own personal hell again known for his
fear of enclosed spaces his punishment
season stuck in an elevator with all
manner of things happening around him
including a coughing man who Taps into
Sal's germaphobia and a cat again Sal
isn't aware that he's being punished
until after the whole thing is over and
he spots a hidden camera though the
strangers are in on the joke it
eventually leads to Sal asking mechanics
and firefighters to help free them it's
a pretty unlucky ending for Sal who
wasn't the only cast member to lose in
the episode's 3 challenges
crazy on the way to his punishment Sal
lost lexicon artists when he was unable
to get someone to agree that a made-up
word is real and failing to get a lady's
number in the getting unlucky challenge
one of Q's most memorable punishments is
seen in season threes just say no where
as the title suggests Q's punishment is
to go to a baseball stadium and simply
say no to everyone he interacts with
what he doesn't know is that a beautiful
woman is waiting to publicly ask him to
marry her
no though she's in on the joke she sets
up a backstory of them being together
for seven years making the inevitable
outcome of onlookers gasping and booing
even more painful to watch some who
claimed to have been at the game itself
revealed that no one in the crowd there
knew it was coming or even that Q was
actually a TV star since the show was
still relatively young even though fans
might feel it's impossible to decide
which are the best punishments Q often
takes a top spot
Murr doesn't have a whole lot of hair to
begin with but that doesn't mean that
he's not devastated to part with what he
has by the season 5 episode brow beaten
the gang decides that now is the perfect
time to shave off all of Mer's hair
including his eyebrows if that weren't
punishment enough there's also a
follow-up for murder to endure with the
guys taking him to be photographed for a
new driver's license since it doesn't
expire until March 2026 mer may still be
out there walking around with a totally
bald ID you look like a demon it's also
a punishment that sets Mur up for
further humiliation to come a season 6
punishment results in myrrh wearing a
wig made out of Q's hair for the
remainder of the season
sometimes a punishment is so bad that
even the Impractical Jokers team
acknowledges it as one of the worst the
season 5 episode Spider-Man puts Q's
Arachnophobia to the test strapping him
to a board while the others torment him
with a remote controlled spider which is
then swapped out for real-life
tarantulas once he settled in it might
seem like a particularly cruel
punishment but it must be something Q
was relatively up for of course he was
also given a safe word which they
ignored public
not only does the punishment set the
other Jokers up to later have q take his
revenge on them but the episode itself
puts Q through the ringer too unable to
eat sushi during fishy business Q loses
out and gets pretty irate with his
friends Q also fails to get the most
hands raised while teaching a hardware
Workshop in Brooklyn in the episode's
second standoff power tools
the season 6 episode rubbed the wrong
way proves that the best punishments for
Joe are ones where he has no control
seeing that he has absolutely no shame
in the episode's punishment Joe has to
portray a Genie in a play with the other
guys controlling his harness and
smashing him into props and set pieces
Genie does as you wish it's a sequence
of actual injuries a near-malfunction
that almost takes off his pants and
smashing through a window
congratulations
trick into thinking the gang was
teaching others how to jump out of
planes the reveal that skydiving is in
fact murr's punishment is almost as
satisfying as watching the distress on
his face during the flight the season 3
premiere episode Look Out Below has mer
losing two out of three challenges
earlier refusing to take a little boy's
hat and throw it later invention
intervention shows teams pitching their
fake inventions with Merr bringing in
the lowest show of hands the result was
one of the most iconic punishments on
the show
[Music]
it's no secret that Myrrh is absolutely
terrified of heights in a 2016 interview
with sling television he described how
pushing each other to the limit is
exactly what solidifies their friendship
a few seasons ago they threw me out of
an airplane and it was hysterical
because I cried like a very young school
child it was so funny and terrifying
we're always pushing boundaries but we
know generally we're not going to kill
anybody or rob a bank other than that I
think anything's game
cells back in the loser seat in the
season 3 episode toasted being forced to
deliver a terrible wedding speech on a
random couple's big day you know it's
pretty terrible because it's been
written by the other Jokers but the
couple were in on the joke your
beautiful inside and out I should know
viewers found the whole ordeal painfully
awkward and it's also been voted as one
of the most cringe-worthy punishments of
all time on the show according to the
show's Instagram page a handful of
wedding guests recognized Sal when he
went up to give his speech but the
shocked reaction of most of the audience
didn't do anything to ease his pain I
run a project where I bring pictures of
all different girls in bikinis to
prisoners in exchangeable woodworkings
MERS time in the piercing chair is
enough to deem it as one of the best
punishments of all time thanks to the
so-called wheel of piercings which
determines exactly where the victim will
be getting new jewelry when he fails to
answer personal trivia questions murr's
final tally ends up being two nipple
piercings and a belly button piercing
though some fans think that Murr can
actually pull the body jewelry off many
agree that this is in line with some of
the show's best old school punishments
the pain wasn't just physical much like
Mer's earlier lie detector punishment he
was forced to reveal a number of
embarrassing details about himself in
the process Murrah later brushed off the
apparent pain in a tweet saying I was
born with abnormally hard nipples what
are you doing I'm feeling which one is
more sensitive oh God oh God it's just
so weird like that considering mer
skydiving punishment is easily
considered one of his personal worst
it's no surprise that he would want
revenge for it he gets the opportunity
in the season 3 finale brother-in-laws
by blindfolding and strapping cell down
to wheel him to a mystery location
[Music]
sorry I swear to God a church where he
watches myrrh marry his sister Jenna it
might be as much of a surprise to learn
that myrrh was in fact legally married
to Sal's sister though it was annulled
after one day though the disapproval is
clear throughout the punishment Sal is
physically unable to object after having
his mouth duct taped shut it takes him a
whole season to get his revenge with the
season 4 finale seeing Murr reveal a
chest shaved to form a coconut bra in a
public park where a flash mob destroys a
replica of his childhood blanket
in the season 3 episode in four taste
buds the team ups the ante on a tried
and tested public speaking punishment by
introducing another element Murr must
pretend to be a culinary expert while
presenting foods from around the world
but he can't taste speak clearly or
really control his mouth at all after
being injected with novocaine it's the
perfect way to thwart the usually smooth
talking myrrh braised raised Leaf is
this is one that leaves mer particularly
red-faced he'd already been humiliated
by being made to ask clients to
participate in strip tennis in the
tennis Chumps challenge while posing as
an instructor on the court making that
the only failed challenge of the entire
episode
if you ever needed proof that Myrrh is
dealt a pretty harsh hand in terms of
punishments the fact that he ends up
having two prostate exams on Impractical
Jokers says it all the most famous of
the two occurs in the season 5 episode
Dark Side of the Moon in which Moore has
to volunteer for a free exam by one
doctor though It ultimately leads to
another one for a second opinion though
some fans might say that this punishment
goes too far it's also a great example
of awareness with murder taking it all
in stride is something that needs to be
done
on television in a 2016 interview with
the Green Bay Press Gazette Murr
explained that there was an added
benefit to going through the ordeal
saying a month ago in front of a room
full of 50 guys they had two doctors
give me two different prostate exams but
you'll be glad to know my prostate looks
good
are the permanent punishments in
Impractical Jokers the scariest
according to Q the answer is a definite
yes in the season 3 episode the
permanent punishment Q Murr and Sal all
have a three-way punishment after losing
a challenge attaching balloons to
customers without getting caught Joe
gets to choose an embarrassing tattoo
for each and he makes some incredible
choices playing into each of their
insecurities already explored throughout
the series
except for Sal who has absolutely no
association with his tattoo
while answering fan questions in a
behind the scenes interview
confirmed that his tattoo was the
scariest punishment he ever took part in
it's something he's been able to take in
stride as the years have passed tweeting
in 2022 46 lives alone has three cats
Sal's tattoo would come up a few more
times in challenges including the
punishment in season 4's Blind Justice
in which he had to show off his prison
tattoo to a bunch of senior citizens Sal
would even show off his Jaden Smith
tattoo to Jaden Smith himself years
later and get a second one fans of the
show look back at it as one of the
funniest punishments of all time even
considering how betrayed the Francine at
the end of the day it's best summed up
by Joe's initial reasoning for picking
something permanent
[Music]
thank you
it's money